President Joe Biden, who some on the
left framed as a neo liberal warmonger,
thirsty for wars and colonialism around the
world, wants to completely reexamine and evaluate
the global troop presence of the United States
and maybe decrease it in some significant way. And
what's interesting about this story, it's not
been getting a lot of attention, and it's not
surprising to me that it's not getting a lot of
attention because this is the exact type of story
that does terribly when we talk about it,
because the sensible left is sort of like,
yeah, we sort of knew that Biden wasn't a
bloodthirsty warmonger. So this isn't surprising.
The anti Biden left just doesn't want to hear
it because it runs counter to their narrative
and it's really what the right expects. I mean,
I know that the right under Trump cheered this
talking point of Trump didn't start any new
wars, but it's not actually their preferred
position on foreign policy. The preferred position
of the reactionary right is Democratic presidents
are weak because they don't want to use the
military and they often want to shrink the
military. That's the lane in which the right is
most comfortable critiquing Democratic presidents.
So the news is to start at the beginning that
the Joe Biden administration has launched a
full systemic review of the global presence of
the U.S. military to ensure that it is, quote,
correctly sized and supports strategy. So at the
top, that's not the language of our military's
presence is too small and we should figure
out ways to make it much bigger. That's kind
of the starting point. Foreign policy analysts
believe that this is exactly the type of review
that could lead to recommendations to reduce
the number of bases abroad, something I've been
talking about for a decade, reduce the number of
troops deployed around the world. Now, of course,
we should all be skeptical that it will turn into
action, given two things. Number one, given all of
the different ways that Republicans can obstruct,
we have to wonder whether even a recommendation of
reducing the U.S. global troop presence will
turn into into a reality. On the other hand,
we've also heard this from other presidents,
right? I mean, we we heard this from Obama.
We've even heard it from Republican presidents and
rarely do things change dramatically. Right now,
the US has about 800 quote, bases around the
world. It's an incredible top number. The truth
is that includes some very small outposts that few
of us would see a picture of and say that's a base
all the way up to massive complexes with thousands
of troops and their families. I mean, just huge
installations. Germany is a place where there
are many there are some in Italy. Many of these
are essentially vestiges of the Cold War that we
really don't need and arguably are a detriment
to American foreign policy. And for me, this
is not just a moral issue, although it is one,
but it's also an economic issue. We talk
about tax rates and how we can afford things
that some want to do. Putting aside for a
second modern monetary theory and a more
nuanced understanding of debt and deficit. And
putting aside the macroeconomic discussion,
the micro of the budget is not trivial. Half of
American discretionary spending is on military
and defense. So we can talk about tax rates,
of course. And last week we talked about, OK,
do should we raise taxes on people making over
400000 or over a million or over two million?
Where should it be? But imagine without.
Changing anything about taxation, taxation,
what we could afford with current tax revenues,
if we change spending priorities and reduce the
amount that we're spending on defense and
the military, and without a doubt, there's
a huge I'll believe it when I see it component,
as I mentioned earlier. But this is sort of like a
wow, what what is the truth of Biden's
foreign policy? And to be clear,
this is not a wow. Biden is the super progressive
on foreign policy. Absolutely not. That's not
what I'm saying. The point here is just like
some on the left insisted Hillary would have
started five new wars and there was really no
reason to believe that that's what would happen.
The people expecting Biden to do the same
and to grow the troop presence are going to
be disappointed. Now, Joe Biden did decide
to pause and reexamine troop withdrawals
that were started or at least announced by Donald
Trump. I'm talking about Afghanistan and Germany,
where Trump said, let's pull out. And Joe Biden
got in and said, we're going to pause that.
Let's wait and see, OK? Because the position
of the Biden administration is essentially,
these are my words, not theirs. But this is the
way I understand it. Trump was so incompetent that
it's worth reviewing everything Trump was in the
middle of before we decide whether to continue it.
My hope is that Biden reviews those two
withdrawals, Germany and Afghanistan,
and does this bigger reevaluation and says,
let's continue and then let's do more.
At the same time, troops in Germany is far
less controversial than many other deployments.
And so I think that the U.S. has a
comically high number of bases in Germany
and many of them are completely unnecessary. I
don't know that I would have would have started in
Germany necessarily. When I think about reducing
our troops spread around the world, it doesn't
matter. The point is we're going to wait and
see what Joe Biden actually decides on those
two. We're also going to see what the outcome
is of this systemic review of the global troop
presence around the world. And I'm not I know
some people will write to me and say, David,
you're so naive. He's not doing anything.
The point is, there was a narrative about.
Biden's going to start all these new
wars, he's going to be the neo liberal,
you know, dominionist of some kind. There
was never any evidence of that. And so far,
what we're seeing is also not indicative of that.
If you disagree with me, let me know. You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. And this Friday,
it's finally time. This Friday, March 26th,
we are doing a one day membership bonanza. We're
looking for massive dumps of new memberships to
make up for a really crappy February. If you want
to be notified of this one day membership special,
it's very easy to get on my newsletter at David
Pakman Dotcom Friday you'll get an email telling,
telling you everything you need to know and
probably even some things you don't need to know.